[Musique]
ça lui est ce que vous aimez les films
de braquage genre ocean's eleven ou les
séries genre la casa des papes elle moi
perso j'adore ça et là je vous ai trouvé
une histoire qui vaut son pesant de
dollars une histoire vraie incroyable
récente que je vais vous raconter quand
j'aurais enlevé ça parce que la vache
c'est insupportable et cagoules et
comment les mecs ils font ça faut avoir
du courage quand même pour faire un
braquage parce qu'on peut pas respirer
la source le 17 février 2003 le gardien
d'un complexe belge sera sécurisé est
arrivé et il a trouvé la salle des
coffres ouverte l'équivalent de 100
millions d'euros avait été dérobé
pendant le week end c'est le casse de ce
début du xxième siècle les cambrioleurs
ont fait le coup sans violence sans
déclencher d'alarmé sans tirer un seul
coup de feu alors la grande question
c'est comment est-ce qu'ils ont faits
qui étaient ces cambrioleurs de génie de
génie presque parce qu'ils sont quand
même fait quelques erreurs
restez bien je vais tout vous raconter
durant cette vidéo d'ailleurs c'est la
rentrée pour beaucoup d'entre vous et
nous aussi on a une sorte de casse du
siècle à vous proposer en tout cas c'est
un excellent plan le coup de génie de la
dernière décennie est attribué à bach
market vous voulez vous procurer du
matériel électronique ou électroménager
performant en excellente état et surtout
à tarif réduit alors rester là parce que
bach marque est partenaire de la vidéo
une solution pour vous et en plus c'est
écologique ça ça fait plaisir je vous en
reparle dans la vidéo loïc
[Musique]
notre personnage principal s'appelle
leonardo notarbartolo il est né à
palerme en 1952 c'est un sicilien et il
fait parler 8 dès l'âge de 6 ans ses
taux quand sa mère lui donne quelques
pièces pour acheter une bouteille de
lait il va chez le laitier arrivé sur
place le laitier est endormi leonardo
prend une bouteille est plutôt que de
laisser l'argent sur la caisse il prend
2 3 bouteilles en plus ils révèlent pas
le métier et il sort 5000 dire de la
caisse et rentre à la maison c'est à
dire qu'il n'avait pas assez d'avoir
volé les bouteilles en plus il lui a
pris tout l'argent pour lui faire passer
l'envié de recommencer sa mère le bas
autre époque autres moeurs mais de toute
manière c'est trop tard une vocation est
née leonardo multiplie les vols arrivés
en une trentaine d'années leonardo
constitue une équipe de talent de
talents spécifiques constitué d'experts
en alarme expert en serrure expert en
coffre fort et sans talent à lui un
autre bateau l'eau c'est un charme et
une gueule de type parfaitement honnête
le meilleur proue de cambrioleurs de
l'époque n'est alors sous le nom de
l'école de turin fin de l'année 2000
leonardo approche la cinquantaine et il
commence avec les chiens à son assurance
retraite il s'en va alors pour anvers en
belgique avec un objectif très précis en
tête
le diamant center
[Musique]
le diamant center est une entreprise
privée située dans le bâtiment d'un des
bâtiments du kilomètre du gamin 80% des
diamants bruts en circulation passe par
ici et pour protéger leurs précieux bien
les diamantaires dispose d'une des
salles des coffres des plus sécurisés de
la page pour l'atteindre rien de plus
simple l'entrée du bâtiment est à 30
mètres du poste de police après passer
devant les 80 caméras extérieures vous
entrez dans le hall et vous buvez votre
badge personnel
en fait c'est là que tout commence vous
arrivez au deuxième ce sol devant une
porte blindée un beau bébé de 3 tonnes
et 61 cm d'épaisseur conçu pour résister
à 12h de perçage d'affilée le gardien
déverrouille avec une clé quasiment
impossible copier il rentre ensuite la
bonne combinaison parmi les 100 millions
de possibilités puis t'as pas de code
notre coq qui désactive la larme
magnétique une fois ouverte s'est pas
terminée il débrouillé une porte
grillagée en acier à l'intérieur de
capteurs de lumière et le capteur de
mouvement et de capteurs de chaleur ont
bien sûr été d active entourée de murs
en béton et sous l'oeil d'une caméra
vous ouvrir enfin l'un des 180 coffre à
l'aide de votre clé et de la bonne
combinaison parmi des 17000 possible un
véritable escape d inverser grandeur
nature
[Musique]
quand leonardo arrive à anvers mais
prend un appartement à deux pas du
quartier des diamantaires et crée
ensuite une société fictive la preciosa
qu'il ne prend même pas la peine non
enregistrées au registre du commerce il
prend directement rendez vous avec la
gérante du diamant center il prétend
être venu ici pour faire du business
entre turin et anvers nos tares matelot
ne fera aucune transaction au nom de sa
société mais ça ils se gardent bien de
le dire à la gérant il présente
parfaitement son affaire la gérante
accepte sa demande et lui donne le
bureau numéro 64 au cinquième étage du
bâtiment b une place de parking en plus
et un coffre ford salle des coffres pour
700 euros par mois la suite s'avère être
plus longue et plus complexe leonardo va
observer les allées et venues de tous
les employés du bâtiment il va tous
notés et surtout faire l'inventaire de
tous les systèmes de sécurité pour
trouver ensuite un moyen de les déjouer
[Musique]
leonardo fait le voyage deux fois par
mois au bout de deux longues années il
établit un plan et appelle plusieurs
hommes de l'école de turin notamment
elio d'onorio le génie experts en
électronique ferdinand tofino tôt un
homme grand et musclé qu'on surnomme le
monstre et pietro cabano surnommé speedy
à l'ami de trente ans de notarbartolo un
peu parano qui intègre laventure malgré
les réticences des autrement l'équipe
est constituée le casse aura lieu le 15
février 2003 13 février 2003 deux jours
avant le casse le diamant de center
reçoit une livraison de deux billards la
société d'extraction de diamant la plus
grosse du monde les coffres sont plaints
14 février 2003 nous sommes à une
journée seulement ducasse leonardo se
rend à son coffre les gardons confiance
et ne prête pas une attention
particulière aux caméras de surveillance
ce jour là
la surveillance est devenu une routine
seul notarbartolo sur une bouteille de
lacq et tartines le détecteur de chaleur
qui ne décèle alors plus les différences
de température dans la pièce le
détecteur de mouvement qui fonctionne de
pair avec ce dernier est lui aussi
neutralisés ce sera sept mois pour le
cast du parlement
[Musique]
samedi 15 février dans la soirée jour j
venus williams se jouent les
demi-finales des diamants games le
tournoi de tennis d'anvers toute la
ville est réunie devant le match les
membres de l'école de turin en profite
pour s'arrêter en plus de 307 derrière
le diamant center il débranche un
capteur de chaleur et rentre par une
porte dérobée notarbartolo reste à
l'extérieur la vidéo surveillance
fonctionnent mais aucun garde n'est
présent le week end il est arrivé à la
porte blindée ils ont la combinaison
grâce à une caméra cachée au dessus de
la porte par notarbartolo la clé est
dans un petit local à côté du hall il
avait réussi à en faire une copie au cas
où le premier obstacle est donc la larme
magnétique qui se déclenche quand léman
fixé sur la porte élément fixe et sur le
mur sont désolidarisés d'onorio fixe une
plaque métallique sur les deux aimants
puis davis celui fixé à la porte alarme
neutraliser avant d'ouvrir il récupère
la clé de la porte grillagée dans le
petit local
pinoteau entre dans le noir et relie les
câbles électriques du capteur de lumière
pour fermer le circuit électrique
désormais que les capteurs se déclenche
ou non la larme restera muet par
sécurité il scotche le capteur de
lumière met une boîte de polystyrène sur
le capteur de chaleur laqué et de
travail qu'à la lampe frontale il ouvre
une centaine de coffres avec leurs
outils maison au bout de cinq heures il
remonte charge la voiture notarbartolo
conduit les autres rentrent à pied le
casse parfait avant de continuer
laissez-moi vous reparler d'un autre cas
celui du sponsor de la vidéo qui mélange
technologie économie et oui c'est
possible pour ceux qui ne les
connaissent pas bach markets et le site
leader en france de vente de produits
électroniques et électroménagers
reconditionnés c'est à dire au mit en
parfait état dans des usines
spécialisées à la rentrée scolaire la
liste des fournitures peut être très
très onéreuse est difficile à financer
pour un portefeuille étudiants par
exemple surtout lorsqu'il faut en plus
renouveler son ordinateur son smartphone
et ou sa tablette alors pour bien
commencer l'année et rentrez dans vos
frais d'acte market qui proposent déjà
des offres allant jusqu'à -70% toute
l'année vous propose une offre étudiante
vous pouvez donc bénéficier de -5 % de
réduction supplémentaire sur un produit
au choix simplement vous inscrivant bien
mon lien dans la description c'est
simple c'est rapide c'est écologique le
casse parfait
[Musique]
il monte dans l'appartement de leonardo
et fonds de partage il met dans des sacs
poubelle tout ce qui pourrait être
compromettant comme les bandes des
caméras de vidéosurveillance et se
sépare en voiture speedy et notarbartolo
partent ensemble avec les sacs poubelles
que ne tarde bateau l'eau veut brûler
mais une fois sur l'autoroute speedy
devient paranoïaque il devient ingérable
il faut arrêter la voiture prend les
sacs les jette au dessus de la glissière
de sécurité
les branches d'arbres les evs entre
leonardo et fou de rage mais le mal est
fait ils s'en vont lundi 17 février 2003
7 heures du matin un gardien du diamant
center d'hommes alerte les agents à jean
de brouckère et pas tripette du diane
squad c'est la brigade du quartier
commentaires arrivent sur place atterré
et fascine et en même temps leur premier
réflexe est d'appeler le service de
gestion des alarmes
alors quel est l'état de la larme là
actuellement tout à fait fonctionnel
d'accord alors expliquez-moi comment ça
se fait que je me trouve à l'intérieur
du coffre fort il y a très peu dans
l'iss l'enquète va être très long mais
quelques heures plus tard august 24
appelle la police après avoir trouvé des
sacs poubelles suspect dans son bois qui
est située au bord de l'autoroute les
enquêteurs vont y trouver une facture au
nom de la société de notarbartolo une
carte de visite de d'onorio et deux
tickets de caisse qui mettront à
d'onorio et fine auto directement en
analysant les réseaux de téléphones
portables qui est trop tavano est
également suspect mais comment leur
mettre la main dessus pour l'un d'entre
eux la question ne se posera pas le
vendredi suivant notarbartolo est de
retour à anvers il entre au diwan center
et se renseigne sur l'état de son coffre
l'air de rien le dire 'mon squad reste
courtois jusqu'à ce qu'il donne
l'adresse de son appartement puis des
enquêteurs lui passer les menottes sur
place la femme de notarbartolo et un
couple d'amis sont en train de vider les
lieux notamment un tapis sur lequel
plusieurs pierres précieuses sont restés
entre les fibres
[Musique]
notarbartolo restera muet comme une
tombe émirats sa responsabilité dans ce
cambriolage
il sera condamné à 10 ans de prison en
tant que cerveau de la faire ses trois
coéquipiers seront arrêtés en 2007 et
feront cinq ans de prison la femme et le
couple d'amis seront relâchés faute de
preuves contre eux un cinquième voleurs
n'auraient jamais été identifié par la
police le butin quant à lui ne sera
jamais retrouvé notarbartolo la police
et les journalistes ont des versions de
cette histoire parfois très différentes
en 2009 le renardeau affirmera qu un
diamantaire véreux du diamant center
l'aurait recruté mais qu'à la
répartition du butin beaucoup de sacs de
diamant était vide il aurait été plus
proche des 20 millions que des 100
millions d'euros de diamants espérer
après le renardeau le diamantaire aurait
prévenu certains de ses collègues pour
qu'ils retirent leurs diamants des
coffres juste avant le casse mais tout
en demandant l'indemnisation par les
assurances par la suite la paramount a
acquis les droits de cette histoire il
ya une dizaine d'années pour en réaliser
un film qui n'a toujours pas vu le jour
merci encore à bach market d'avoir
sponsorisé cette ville et de mettre en
place des offres étudiants que ça c'est
très cool vous pouvez profiter de la
réduction dès maintenant via le lien de
la description merci à vous d'avoir
regardé la vidéo je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard vous pouvez vous abonner
à cette chaîne c'est gratuit c'est pas
ce pas un casque et pas de cap pas de
stratégie c'est assez facile à faire
petit message aussi pour vous dire que
ce soir je suis un spectacle à lille
alors c'est déjà complet mais la tournée
a repris elle continue pour une
trentaine de villes je vais très bientôt
à saint-amand-les-eaux à
fleury-les-aubrais à bordeaux à
gérardmer à toulouse à nantes etc une
trentaine de villes jusqu'au zénith de
paris la grande dernière le 11 décembre
pour vous informer au réservé pour cette
date de spectacl lien est également dans
la description on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour matières résumé rose la
fin de la saison une avec ludovic bu on
va parler du fait qu'on ce n'est
prévisible aussi bien le corps que
l'esprit et puis si je vous mets deux
autres vidéos cabinet quorus 4 c'est sur
l'île de pâques et une vidéo sur les
super héros et leur impact dans notre
société a new réel prenez soin de vous
et à très bientôt ciao